this woman at the end of her life was  reflecting on her meditation practice  and she said that every itch not  scratched was a lesson in compassion  whether it's a physical itch or a mental  itch something comes up and you want to  deal with it and learning to let it be  there  helps you become a more compassionate  person to yourself to others because we  all have all these itches that we want  to scratch all the time and it's so hard  to live a life where we're bombarded  with these things that we want to fix  with loss with disappointment with all  these things and learning to accept it  if that doesn't make you a more  compassionate person then like what will